hi guys I'm Eric box and I just finished
watching Logan in I don't think a
superhero movie could make me feel this
much actually didn't think anything
could make me feel this much because
I've been desensitized from watching
Hugh Jackman turn hundreds of men into
mincemeat for the past 17 years anyway
go watch Logan it's amazing I can't wait
to talk about it but in this video I'm
going to talk about something a bit more
lighthearted the preview scene for
Deadpool - that played before the movie
well maybe it did a lot of people are
saying that they're screening didn't
have it and I don't know why maybe you
live in another country or like God just
doesn't love you but I got you covered
also relax merely knowing that Deadpool
is in the scene isn't really a spoiler
but everything I'm about to say is so
you've been warned okay here's what goes
down Deadpool Wade Wilson is on his way
into a screening of the movie Logan at a
Cineplex
listening to Angel the morning like at
the beginning of the Deadpool movie but
then Wade notices an old man getting
mugged and he says not today
[ __ ] then John Williams iconic
Superman theme plays as Wade dashes into
a phone booth we change into his
Deadpool suit but rather than speeding
through it elegantly like the Man of
Steel can Wade takes a full clumsy
minute and at one point it's bare ass
presses against the door meanwhile we
hear the mugging get worse outside as
the old man screams for help and then
get shot then Deadpool runs to find a
man dead and he uses his body as a
pillow and eats his Cherry Garcia ice
cream and jokes that he would still be
alive if Logan was there cut - Deadpool
title no release day for Deadpool - and
a seemingly random text scroll of a plot
synopsis - the old man in the sea by
Ernest Hemingway okay so I loved this
scene and I think it was a good move to
play it before Logan because it would
feel really weird as a post-credits
scene after the movie like Logan in so
perfectly importantly and this Deadpool
scene would kind of [ __ ] on that so
instead this scene kind of works like
one of those Pixar shorts that play
before those movies this scene also had
a few Easter eggs if you were watching
closely so the first was graffiti on the
phone booth had said Nathan summers
coming soon coming spelled in the
totally crass but totally Deadpool
spelling with tumm
and we already knew he was going to be
in Deadpool - since that post-credit
scene after the Deadpool movie in 2016
but a quick reminder
or cable Nathan summers is the son of
Scott Summers and a version of Jean Grey
and it's backstories very complicated
that involves time travel oh yeah I'm
not going to get into it but this
character is awesome he has a bionic arm
in a techno-organic eye he also has some
telekinetic and telepathic power but
really cable took off in a team of comic
series cable and Deadpool so these two
are really just made for each other and
we still don't really know which actor
is going to play cable some people are
saying that Pierce Brosnan might be
being considered since he showed up in
that Instagram post with Ryan Reynolds
as Hugh Jackman and recently David
Harbor from stranger things read for the
part so then in another shot you can see
in the background these posters for the
show Firefly now that could be a nod to
Joss Whedon he created the show and he
directed Avengers 1 & 2 and he was
rumored to direct Deadpool to after Tim
Miller left the project but then we
learned later that John wick director
david leitch is taking over Deadpool 2
and he directed this scene as his head
actually did a pretty good job anyway
Firefly was also a well respected series
that balanced Western and sci-fi genres
and that's kind of what Logan is a
Western filled with a bunch of sci-fi
elements that also could be why it was
included and then finally why do we see
this plot summary of the old man in the
sea well if you know anything about that
novel it actually parallels the story of
another old man Logan pretty closely
it's about an old washed-up fisherman
who goes out for one last big test to
redeem himself he's able to catch this
massive Marlin but he injures himself
trying to haul it back in and then as he
brings it back to land a bunch of sharks
tear away at it so that really all
that's left of the fish is a skeleton
and he feels like a failure but then
other fisherman see this huge skeleton
and know that he scored this big victory
and it ends with this little boys
sidekick who cries at his bedside when
he sees the old man's injured hand
similarly Logan is a washed-up old man
destroying his body to redeem himself
and it ends with kind of the same image
with his hands bloodied up and Lora
crying over him so yeah Deadpool is
trying to spoil the end of the freakin
movie here thanks dude alright that
covers the Deadpool preview scene now I
got a few other videos on Logan plans to
keep an eye out for those and let me
know what you think in the comments
about this scene or what you like most
about Logan and make sure to LIKE this
video into
two new rock stars and you really like
us you can contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our current donors
you can hit me up on Twitter a TA box
with any thoughts you had about Deadpool
or Logan or follow a new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars for updates on
our videos alright thanks for watching